فوق هذا الرصيف وسط مديريه الشيخ عثمان
بعدن يعيش عشرات المهاجرين الافارقه
ويتخذون من المكان سكرا وهو ما يتسبب
بمشكلات لا حصل لها كما تقول السلطات
المحليه اذا كانوا يمر يوم من دون تسجيل
وصول عشرات المهاجرين من دول القرن
الافريقي وخصوص الاثيوبيا الهجره
الافارقه الى الى عدن سبنا مشكله مشكله
امنيه مشكله صحيه ايضا انتشارهم
السكنيه
كان في الاخير نحن نتعامل مع جانب انساني
وقدم لهم كل الشيلات والخدمات نحن التقينا
مع الهجره الدوليه مؤخرا وتم عدد اللقاء
لقاء عده من سابك وهو كيفيه عوده هذه
المهاجرين الى مناطقم وخاصه وهجره غير
الشرعيه وليس ولا يدخلوا في اطار اللاجئين
يشكلها اول كبيره وضعتني وفاقم من الازمات
التي تعيشها وتعاني منها مدينه عدن
والمحافظات المجاوره
ويتدفق شهريا عبر الشواطئ الجنوبيه للبلاد
6000 مهاجر بمعدل شهري وتقول السلطات ان
هؤلاء المهاجرين يدخلون بشكل غير شرعي وان
معظمهم يرفضون البقاء في مخيمات الاستقبال
لينتشروا بشكل غير منظم في الاسواق
والشوارع والاحياء ويعيشون في العراق
بمساعده ما يفوق 3000 مهاجر همم بالعوده
الطبيعيه من اصل طبعا الرقم في ارتفاع همم
بسبب تزايد عدد المهاجرين الموجودين هنا
والذين تقاطعت بهم السبل والذين يطلبون
طبعا مساعده همم المنظمه الدول والهجره
في شوارع مدينه عدن اصبح ظاهره تؤرق
السكان بما يجبهم من المشكلات وتداعيات
وانتشار للجريمه
والاستغلال الذي وصل الى حد تجنيد بعضهم
واستخدامهم في تنفيذ عمليات ارهابيه من
قبل تنظيم القاعده والحسين
انه نحن بالرحل ولكن العدد ما زالت تتواصل
علينا وكان هناك في غدا اجتماع بالخارجيه
اليمنيه مع الحكومه الاثيوبيه على دوله
عقد مؤتمر الدولي للحد من الهجره هذه
الافريقي كررت سلطاته عدن والحكومه
الدعوات لمنظمه الهجره الدوليه للمساعده
في ايجاد حلول لمشكله المهاجرين من
افريقيا وحتى تاتي استجابتهم تاخرت كثيرا
تبقى هذه الظاهره واحده من اكبر المشاكل
التي تواجهها ذلك العربيه